we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p i got a
voicemail that relates to something
we've been talking about regarding the
pipe bombs and real-world violence and
domestic terror take a listen
so how's it going hey man what you gonna
say when it turns out that uh you
so-called pop moms are nothing but
something democrats hooked up themselves
I can't wait till it comes out and all
you liberals have to retract your
statements yeah one by one by one it's
gonna be beautiful I think you'll just
drop the score immediately no I see it's
like the worst attack since 911
ba-ba-ba-ba-ba but it's not because
they're not even real bombs and it's
gonna be a little the desert I guarantee
you it'll be a liberal just be why I
would probably a subscriber of yours
well it ain't gonna be this liberal not
one bit what we have here is a situation
where Caesar Sayaka indeed was a right
winger and he had a van covered in
stickers that are pro-trump and
anti-hillary he was a regular fixture at
Trump rallies he in fact journalists
have been going back through the records
of their pictures from Trump events and
they found his presence at a number of
these and nobody's going to have to
retract anything and and the only part
even really worth focusing on is this
issue of fake bombs the fact that the
bombs didn't go off and the fact that
the guy didn't really seem to know
exactly how to make bombs that would go
off doesn't actually excuse what he did
they were packed with glass and other
materials meant to be shrapnel
they had a explosive powder in them
these were real bombs and whether they
did or didn't go off he should be lucky
that they didn't go off in a sense
although I have a feeling that in the
end it's gonna be a pretty harsh
sentence for this guy but consider what
would have happened if indeed these
bombs had gone off and so calling them
fake bombs don't don't fall for that
this is your brain on trumpism and no
liberal is going to be taking anything
back because nobody said anything that
was wrong in sort of the bigger picture
progressive media narrative okay briefly
we're in the new studio I'm gonna talk
about it on the bonus show today we have
had some tech issues today but big
picture I am really pleased with how
things are going please let me know how
the audio is sounding please let me know
how things are looking I am aware of the
fact that my one of my lights reflects
in the TV behind me and we've got a
couple different things that need to be
dealt with here so we have another
session with our engineer right after we
are finished taping today but overall
things are going in a really really good
direction the video is crisp the video
is clean I like the sort of higher key
lighting our old set was relatively dark
and I hope people will like it the only
real question is are we - am I too close
to you is it uncomfortable for the shot
to be so zoomed in because I know that
there are people at the old studio who
would say David we want to be closer to
you we want to see you we want to be
closer to you and now we are and I think
it's horrifying to a lot of people I've
got all sorts of things happening hair
is out of place and skin blemishes that
maybe weren't visible before I don't
want to scare anybody but send me your
feedback we are on the way to finalizing
this set up and it's looking really
really good
we'll speak to you on the bonus show
more about the transition more about the
moving and a brand new program for you
tomorrow